regreso al encierro bogotá a la capital
de colombia volverá a entrar en
cuarentena estricta este fin de semana
así lo anunció la alcaldesa de la ciudad
claudia lópez desde las 8 de la noche
del viernes hasta
a las 4 de la mañana del lunes
volveremos a estar nuevamente todos en
casa el domingo ahora cuarentena general
nuevamente en la ciudad de bogotá el
gobierno local también anunció nuevas
restricciones para varios barrios
bogotanos del sur que se suman a las que
ya imperan en las zonas del norte eso
significa que todo el mes de enero
transcurrirá entre cuarentenas
escalonadas en diferentes localidades de
la ciudad
si opino que los puestos de control
están bien por localidades nos afecta
mucha gente pero tenemos que parar el
contagio son medidas que buscan frenar
la segunda ola de contagios de kobe 19
agravada por las celebraciones y los
viajes de las vacaciones navideñas pero
que evitan el encierro total que se
vivió en marzo abril y mayo en el país
bogotá no es la única ciudad que vuelve
a registrar altas cifras de muertes y
contagios de kobe 19 los hospitales en
cali están desbordados y medellín tiene
más del 85% de las luces ocupadas
ante este panorama el presidente iván
duque recibió críticas por el lento
despliegue del programa de vacunación
que está previsto que empiece en febrero
aunque gran parte de la infraestructura
todavía no está lista
colombia ha asegurado 49 millones de
dosis de vacunas suficientes para
proteger unos 29 millones de personas
poco más de la mitad de la población
total del país